it's interesting because I been thinking
about all of your work and
uh what comes up so often for me this is
my
interpretation uh and and so much
there's been so much discussion of your
work but will there's an iron will that
you have and I'm wondering uh with these
film Productions which are you know
impossible to pull off you're in the
jungle it's things are collapsing you're
your your main actor kinsky wants to
murder you you want to murder him it all
sounds impossible and yet you always
keep going and I'm wondering to move a
ship over a mountain in falo you have to
move a ship over a mountain and you've
made work about how difficult the work
was there documentaries about how
impossible the project is and what I
keep coming back to are a couple of
themes and one is will Iron Will and I'm
wondering was that something in your
opinion is that that in your soul or was
in in your genetics or was that
something that somehow was the product
of having so little growing up I think
it's not a correct description to point
it Iron
Will um because you can dissuade me from
from my will with a real good argument
and I do the doable I really do the
doable I knew I could move a ship over a
mountain in the jungle it can be done
and I knew I would be able to do it
although nobody believed in it anymore
and you become very solitary when there
are 800 people around and nobody
believes in it and the next town where
you can buy a torch light battery is 800
kilometers away so you become very
solitary but it's not I wouldn't call it
Iron Will it's it's a very very clear
Vision yeah okay a very deep vision in
me and I knew moving a ship over a
mountain would be a great metaphor
something like um Mobby dick yes uh the
white whale something embedded very deep
in our soul in our Collective Soul
probably and I can articulate it and all
of a sudden everybody understands
although I I must confess meta for for
what I cannot explain well everyone can
have their own interpretation because
we've all whatever in our lives we've
all we've all pulled a giant ship over a
mountain sure whe uh and when I say that
I mean we've all battled with something
that most people thought well that can't
be done yeah I'm curious if when I look
at your work I think did you
have
um you seem very solid the whole time
even during all this uh insanity and
chaos you seem very solid and I think uh
do you have a good mask a good poker
face or did you feel true true despair
if there's if there's only a mask uh it
it would get cracks and it would become
visible that it's only posing right you
have to you have to have it in you yeah
and um so what can I say uh that has it
has carried me that I'm just myself mhm
and essentially myself in many of the
situations there's another theme that
you you love to explore which is madness
and I I it it comes up again and again
and again uh and I was noticing it even
came up in so many of your films there's
that line between someone being obsessed
and are they have they gone mad have
they lost control of themselves you've
worked with people who uh could
clinically be called mad if that's a
real clinical diagnosis anymore um when
you did your documentary encounters at
the end of the world and you're in
Antarctica I remember very clearly
there's a scene where you're looking at
the Penguins and you start to wonder
have they gone mad um at least one at
least one has there one penguin gone mad
but I thought well Warner Herzog went
all the way to Antarctica and he's
looking at penguins and he's still
wondering about Madness is this what is
what it is it right that that is a that
that is a a true uh that's a theme that
you like to try and
or explore yes it's not only Madness but
a state where we can be out or Beyond
ourselves like an ecstasy like uh
religious Mystics in the late Middle
Ages or it could be a penguin I asked a
penguin research and I was told he has
not spoken to anyone for 24 years so I
said I will be the first one and I I
tell him uh some things that he has
never heard why um do for example
species of ants uh create colonies of
slaves of some sort of lice that they
milk for droplets of uh droplets of
sugar why is that and why does a chimp
not saddle the goat and ride off into
the sunset of Death Valley or Monument
Valley yeah why does this happen uh is
there Insanity among animals not only
among people is there Insanity among
Penguins some because I observed a
penguin that marches right into uh the
continent and it's 5,000 kilometers of
uh of ice and and mountains and there's
no way to turn the penguin around you
can do that and you shouldn't do it by
the way but you can turn it around it
will immediately stubbornly March into
his death into the interior of the
continent not to the water not to the
Colony so what is going on I I've been
fascinated by
this